[Música]
alguns meses atrás eu estava na cozinha
da minha casa e minha filha mais velha
me perguntou pai eu quero fazer pipoca
doce e aí eu fiz a coisa que a coisa
mais natural do mundo peguei meu
telefone
pesquisei e encontrei instantaneamente
uma receita de pipoca doce e nem me
toquei que isso é uma coisa
absolutamente natural da gente fazer
porque nas últimas décadas
a gente se acostumou a usar os
mecanismos de busca para encontrar todo
tipo de informação sobre o conhecimento
humano
esse mecanismo não mudaram a forma como
a gente trabalha mudar a forma como a
gente aprende mudar até mesmo a forma
como a gente se relacionam
agora imagine o que aconteceria se ao
invés de simplesmente responder pra
gente coisa sobre o que a humanidade já
conhece esse tipo de mecanismo pudesse
responder pra gente perguntas para as
quais ninguém ainda sabe a resposta pode
parecer ficção científica é isso que
estou falando
mas se a inteligência artificial
continuar evoluindo na próxima década
com a mesma velocidade com que ela tem
evoluído na última década nos próximos
dez anos nós vamos ter algo muito
parecido com isso nas nossas mãos e isso
vai mudar muito a forma como a sociedade
funciona nos computadores digitais
todas as máquinas que a gente tem desde
os primeiros computadores da década de
40 os computadores que eu aprendi a
programar quando era criança os nossos
smartphones hoje todos são o mesmo tipo
de máquina na computação a gente chama
de máquina de turim em homenagem a um
dos fundadores da computação
essas máquinas foram criadas por que nós
precisávamos melhorar a nossa capacidade
de fazer cálculos matemáticos e de rezou
e de memorizar grande com grandes
quantidades de dados
e elas são muito melhores do que nós
nessas duas tarefas mas em compensação
elas têm uma grande desvantagem sobre
nós
se você quer um computador resolva o
problema
você precisa de escrever
exatamente para esse computador como
esse problema precisa ser resolvido
isso significa que a gente só consegue
usar computadores para resolver
problemas que alguém já sabe como
resolver e até a grande maioria dos
problemas do mundo
não é assim a gente não tem resposta nos
na última década a gente tem visto a
aceleração da utilização de um paradigma
de computação chamado aprendizado de
máquina e aprendizado de máquina é um
paradigma tão antigo quanto os nossos
computadores atuais mas só na última
década a gente passou a ter um volume de
dados e poder de processamento
suficiente para ele fazer diferença a
nossa sociedade
o aprendizado de máquina ele muda o foco
de programar um computador para
simplesmente seguir instruções para
programar um computador para aprender a
resolver um problema
isso porque o aprendizado de máquina usa
três ingredientes
você tem uma descrição de um problema do
mundo real
você tem uma receita que explica para o
computador como aprender a partir de
exemplos e você tem os chamados dados
que são grandes quantidades de exemplos
relacionados a esse problema unido
dessas três desses três ingredientes o
aprendizado de máquina aqui é o nome
acadêmico na verdade do que chama de
inteligência artificial
ele permite que os computadores aprendam
a achar soluções que nenhum ser humano
ainda conhece ea gente tem visto
principalmente nos últimos cinco anos
essa tecnologia sendo utilizado para
responder mais e mais perguntas
a gente começou trabalhando num ambiente
extremamente empresarial
então a gente responde perguntas do tipo
que suprimentos podem atrasar este mês
ou qual o anúncio é mais atrativo para
essa pessoa e se essa é uma pergunta
extremamente polêmico hoje em dia porque
ela está por trás de toda a inteligência
artificial que tem é relacionada à
propaganda mas a gente pode usar essa
tecnologia para ela uma tecnologia de
propósito geral a gente pode usar ela
para qualquer área do conhecimento
humano então a gente pode usar
tecnologia para responder coisas muito
mais fundamentais para a nossa própria
existência
coisas do tipo o que causa a doença de
alzheimer ou qual o melhor tratamento
para um caso específico para um paciente
específico que sofre de dor crónica ou
ainda qual o formato exato
tridimensional da proteína que vai ser
sintetizada por um gene específico de um
micro-organismo
essa é uma pergunta bastante técnica mas
ela pode ser traduzido de uma forma
muito mais simples por como sintetizar
plástico biodegradável
todas essas perguntas são perguntas que
nós eu e meus colegas de trabalho temos
trabalhado nos últimos anos mas a
sociedade como um todo ela criou ela
criou a ideia de que a gente precisa de
profissionais específicos para trabalhar
com é com esse tipo de tecnologia
o professor entende que é um dos grandes
expoentes dessa área na atualidade ele
definiu no tweet em 2016 que a
inteligência artificial é um superpoder
ele talvez tenha exagerado um pouco mas
se a gente pensar que os nossas máquinas
nos computadores eles não são nada mais
do que as tensões nós mesmos se a gente
tinha uma máquina capaz de aprender algo
que a gente não sabe é uma espécie de
super poder é esse e é um superpoder
quem seria então que os super heróis
a gente criou então a figura que é
chamada de cientista de dados sentido de
dados ele é uma espécie de um
profissional multifacetado ele tem que
ter um pouco de programador um pouco de
estatístico e um pouco de contador de
histórias porque o trabalho dele é
traduzir
entre as perguntas do mundo real e o
formalismo matemático que o aprendizado
de máquina precisa para que seja capaz
de entender essas perguntas e
transformá-los numa solução
o cientista de dados trabalha numa
fronteira muito tênue entre o que é
provável que o que é possível e é por
isso que ele é considerado uma das
profissões mais sexy do século 21
é você já deve ter notado que eu sou um
cientista de dados dado como obviamente
sexy eu sou e como cientista de dados
uma pergunta que eu escuto quase que
diariamente é aí vai a inteligência
artificial vai automatizar meu trabalho
e eu nunca sei responder direito porque
depende muito de cada situação mas nos
últimos anos eu tenho começado a dar a
seguinte resposta à inteligência
artificial vai automatizar o meu
trabalho eu digo isso porque por mais
que a profissão seja dolorosa
o mundo precisa de muito mais sentido de
dados do que existem hoje por uma série
de motivos primeiro porque a quantidade
de dados que nós temos no mundo ela
cresce a uma taxa muito maior do que a
gente consegue produzir cientista
ajudados por mais que a nossa sociedade
invista informação e existe uma
quantidade enorme de material e cursos
no entanto dentro das universidades
quanto online com a nossa capacidade de
formar pessoas capazes de dominar essa
tecnologia
ela é muito pai de em comparação com a
quantidade de dados que o mundo produziu
a quantidade de problemas que a gente
poderia estar resolvendo isso faz com
que o cientista de dados se torne um
profissional relativamente bem pago
dentro da área de tecnologia um
profissional caro ea grande maioria das
empresas principalmente as empresas de
grande porte
perceberam nos últimos anos que seus
dados não são um subproduto da operação
delas não são custo é eles são a fonte
de novas idéias são a fonte de novas
fontes de receita são a fonte de novos
produtos desde que eles sejam
processados e processá-los você precisa
de aprendizado de máquina e portanto
sentido de dados faz com que as empresas
que têm capacidade financeira tem maior
capacidade financeira sejam capazes de
montar grandes times de cientistas de
dados e com isso obter uma vantagem
desproporcional no uso do enem
ele gente artificial em detrimento de
empresas menores ou de outros setores da
sociedade onde os problemas não têm o
interesse comercial tão claro por trás
não é à toa que talvez as mais valiosas
empresas hoje no mundo são justamente as
empresas que mais investem em pesquisa e
desenvolvimento em inteligência
artificial modo maneira de tentar
resolver esse problema e essa maneira
que eu e os meus colegas estamos é
tentado na trabalhar é criar maneiras de
tornar a tecnologia mais acessível para
as pessoas e tornar mais simples o uso
da inteligência artificial permitir que
pessoas que tenham que não tem uma
formação tão especializada sejam capazes
de fazer de formular as perguntas de
obter as respostas usando essa
tecnologia a forma como nós em
particular estamos trabalhando isso é
tentar criar uma nova linguagem de
programação pra nós sentido da
computação linguagem uma coisa muito
importante porque ela é como nós nos
comunicamos com as nossas máquinas e nós
estamos criando uma nova linguagem que
vai permitir que pessoas que são
programadores que não tem uma formação
em ciência de dados extensiva sejam
capazes de usufruir da inteligência
artificial hoje que apenas as grandes
empresas conseguem essa pergunta na qual
as chances de um paciente específico
desenvolver alzheimer
nessa nossa linguagem seria traduzido
por esse trecho de código que para quem
não é programador provavelmente dizendo
é tão complicado quanto à inteligência
artificial
mas se você é desenvolvedor ou se você
já trabalhou com o banco de dados se
você conhece ou já ouviu falar de uma
linguagem chamada fql que é utilizada
por milhões de programadores no mundo
inteiro hoje para fazer consultas em
base de dados você vai perceber que o
que a gente está desenvolvendo parece
muito com o que você já conhece
é certo que nessa linguagem você
consegue formular perguntas tanto sobre
o passado dos dados quanto pergunta
sobre o futuro que é onde a gente aplica
inteligência artificial
mato que é chamado de aprendizado de
máquina automatizado
então o primeiro aprendizado de máquina
automatizado
a gente pega uma consulta como essa e
automaticamente gera o sistema de ar por
trás que resolve esse problema
se tudo der certo se essa nossa
iniciativa uma das muitas outras
iniciativas que existem hoje no mundo em
aprendizado de máquina automatizado
funcionarem o que vai acontecer é que
nós vamos entrar numa era onde as coisas
mais importantes que vão que a gente vai
precisar fazer são as perguntas corretas
e não quer dizer que o mundo vai deixar
de precisar de cientistas de dados na
verdade o mundo vai precisar de muito
mais cientista de dados do que a gente
tem hoje porque nós temos muitos
problemas para resolver neste século 21
a humanidade tem muitos e muitos
desafios esses 10 são só última das
listas de principais desafios da
humanidade
então nós claramente a tecnologia não
vai resolver esses problemas sozinha mas
ela pode ser um poderoso aliado na
solução de dos nossos maiores desafios
desde que nós tenhamos capacidade
suficiente de fazer as perguntas certas
como distribuir renda e bem estar como
desenvolver novos antibióticos como
combater o discurso de ódio fake news
como fornecer assistência médica de
ponta fora dos grandes centros urbanos
quando o professor é grande disse que a
inteligência artificial um superpoder a
frase completa dele na verdade foi essa
que está aí
espero que você aprenda inteligência
artificial não por causa dos altos
salários mas porque iríamos superpoder
que permite que você mude mundo nós em
particular
acreditamos muito nessa ideia e o nosso
objetivo é tornar esse superpoder
disponível para o maior número possível
de pessoas
obrigado